The clank of heavy metal bars echoing through
the building usually kept Javi up at night.
But he never thought that he would ever come
to miss that sound one day.
As he tossed and turned in his uncomfortable
bunk, he couldn’t help that the noise reminded
of how confined he was… and how trapped
he felt within.
It had been a mistake, an honest and completely
unpredictable mistake.
On the nights that sleep evaded him, he’d
always replay the events over and over again.
His daughter, Kali, calling him out of the
blue, her distorted, uncontrollable sobs playing
into his ear over the phone.
Javi remembered jumping into his car and flooring
the accelerator, rain drumming against the
windshield
as he drove all the way across town to her
apartment in the early hours of the morning.
And then there was the scene that awaited
him as he stepped through the door,
the mess that had been of her kitchen, covering
the floor, smeared up the walls, even dripping
off the ceiling.
It all stayed there as Javi debated with his
daughter about what they should do next.
She was crying, begging for her dad’s help,
suggesting they should clean the place from
top to bottom
and hide any evidence scattered around the
apartment.
Laying in his cell all those months later,
he sometimes wondered why he said no to that
idea.
Instead, they came up with a story, a falsified
version of events.
Javi made Kali swear to stick to it, no matter
what, and through heavy sobs she agreed.
Then, after they’d been over every detail
and had it perfect, Javi got back in his car
and drove to the nearest police precinct to
turn himself in.
All while taking the fall, pleading guilty
in court and being sentenced to prison,
he reminded himself over and over that he
was doing it for Kali.
No matter what she had done, whatever accidents
had happened, she was still his kid, and he’d
do anything to protect her.
But that was part of what made it sting so
bad.
Not being locked up, but not getting to see
her.
Despite making request after request, Javi
was denied visitation rights,
when seeing his daughter and knowing she was
alright were the only things that would’ve
made this struggle easier.
It was after his twentieth request that a
guard informed Javi he was being moved.
At first, he assumed ‘moved’ meant to
another part of the prison, maybe with more
lax security and the right to see Kali.
But they didn’t mean moved.
They meant transferred…
into the care of an organization Javi came
to know as the SCP Foundation.
It was different here.
The kind of people he was locked up with as
a member of ‘D Class personnel’ were some
of the most heinous criminals on the planet.
But there was something else going on, something
weirder.
Javi would overhear whispers and rumors from
the other D Classes;
they’d talk of experiments conducted by
the Foundation…
with them as the lab rats.
“D-14164,” the researcher greeted him
as he was pulled into a side room, flanked
on all sides by armed Foundation guards.
“Yours is quite the interesting case.
No priors, no criminal affiliations of any
kind, hardly any family to testify to your
innocence.
And yet, what you did…
now, that takes some guts.
If you’ll pardon the pun.”
“So, it’s all true then,” Javi replied
solemnly.
“You’re here to say you want to experiment
on me.”
“I wouldn’t call it an ‘experiment’
per se,” the researcher smiled smugly.
“Let’s use the word… ‘expedition’.
Has a nicer ring to it, don’t you think?”
“An expedition to where?” he asked.
“I’m afraid I can’t tell you that.”
“Then I won’t go,” Javi shrugged.
“Listen closely, D-14164.
The SCP Foundation has… we’ll say a considerable
influence across the globe.
What we’re asking you to agree to is involvement
in possibly one of the most dangerous operations
we have ever conducted.
Now, as unappealing as that might sound, allow
me to sweeten the deal.
Should you say yes, agree to take part, and
follow our instructions, then you might find
that the Foundation’s influence may be rather
beneficial to you… should you survive.”
The researcher paused to push a document across
the table, close enough for Javi to read.
“A clean record, that one nasty mistake
wiped clean for good.
On top of that, an immediate release and a
new identity.
You’d have a second chance, Mr. Garrett.
Both you and your daughter would.”
“And what if I say no?”
Javi asked bluntly.
“Well, that’s your prerogative,” the
researcher replied.
“And we won’t be able to detain you after
releasing evidence of your innocence.
So, you’ll be free no matter what.
Oh, although, your daughter will, of course,
be remanded into custody, given that she is
actually guilty.
Maybe, once we get her move to D Class, she
might be more willing to cooperate than her
dear old dad?”
Under the table, Javi’s hands were shaking
with rage.
He clenched his fist so furiously that the
cuffs felt tighter around his wrists.
The hate in his eyes was palpable as he glared
at the researcher.
It was bad enough that they had backed him
into a corner, put him in a situation wherein
saying yes or no would be equally catastrophic.
But what felt worse was that they knew, they
knew what Kali had done, and they were using
that as a threat.
Taking a deep breath, Javi steadied himself
before finally speaking up again.
“Just tell me what you want me to do.”
Instantly, he felt like he’d been thrown
headfirst into a commotion he could barely
keep up with.
No sooner had he said that, Javi had been
led away by a team of Foundation guards while
the researcher followed, rattling off vague
information about the ‘expedition’.
Guided by the armed escort into another room,
Javi was flocked by more Foundation staff,
strapping electronic equipment over the outside
of his orange prisoner garb.
One piece of it was to monitor his heart rate,
another was a portable camera to record his
surroundings,
although those were among the few details
that he was actually able to catch during
all the activity.
Javi couldn’t help noticing how nobody had
even mentioned just where he was meant to
be going on this expedition,
just that the Foundation wanted to keep a
close eye on him while he was there.
“You still haven’t told me exactly where
it is I’m meant to be going,” he finally
spoke up.
“Or how I’m getting there.”
“All in good time,” the head researcher
replied.
“So far, the only detail you need to be
aware of is this: it’s dangerous.
A particularly hostile environment.”
“So, like a warzone?”
Javi asked.
The researcher smiled, but to themselves,
as if there was something funny about the
question and the lack of understanding it
conveyed.
Javi’s attention was quickly turned to another
D Class, wearing a similar D Class uniform
to him.
The staff began prepping the second convict
in the same room, although without nearly
as much gear as they’d given Javi.
“I thought I was the only one going on this
trip,” he stated.
“Oh, don’t worry, that’s just the lure,”
the researcher explained, though it only raised
more questions.
“They won’t be accompanying you.”
It was then Javi was led out of the prep room,
and walked through the Foundation facility.
The place was a hive of activity, as well
as noise.
There were alien shrieks and wails, monstrous
sounds emanating from deep in the building,
muffled only slightly underneath thick layers
of concrete and heavy steel doors.
On top of that, there were screams, too, distinctly
human sounds of pain and fear.
Javi tried to ignore it as he was instructed
to keep walking, feeling almost nostalgic
for the clank of metal bars back at his old
cell.
He had been anticipating being taken out of
the facility, towards maybe a helipad or runway
where an aircraft would be waiting to fly
him out to his undisclosed destination.
In fact, even a dock with a moored boat would
have been more within the realm of what he
was expected.
But instead, he was taken deeper and deeper
into the Foundation’s sprawling complex,
passing testing areas and containment levels,
through winding corridors until...
Javi was told to stop in front of a heavy
door that held a containment area beyond.
He couldn’t help noticing that the door
itself looked brand new like it had only just
been installed.
Meanwhile, the frame surrounding it had traces
of discoloring and damage, almost as if something
corrosive had melted away the previous door,
hence the replacement.
“This is it?”
Javi asked, confused but still trying to nudge
more information out of the Foundation staff.
“You want me to do an ‘expedition’ within
your own building?”
“Yes and no,” the head researcher replied,
still giving next to no useful details.
“Now, this is important.
Once you get to your destination, we need
you to figure out how to get back to us.
You do that, and you’ll have your freedom,
your daughter, your second chance.”
“Surely to get back I can just open up this
door again?”
the prisoner said.
That garnered a slight chuckle from the researcher,
again seeming to find Javi’s lack of understanding
amusing.
“Oh, D-14164.
If only it was that simple.”
The door opened with a heaving, metallic creak,
and Javi was unceremoniously pushed inside
by the guards.
Staggering inside, catching himself before
he lost his balance and fell over,
he almost turned back to start slamming his
fists against the now-sealed entrance.
He would have, were it not for the sight of
something oozing out of the wall directly
in front of him.
Javi stepped closer to inspect in, but withdrew
his hand as he noticed thick, black droplets
leaking onto the floor.
The substance hissed as it made contact with
the ground, like it was burning through, corroding
whatever it came into contact with.
Keeping himself from touching it, Javi leaned
in to get a closer look…
and found the grotesque face of SCP-106 looking
back at him.
A spindly, decrepit hand reached out of the
gooey puddle and grabbed the orange material
of Javi’s jumpsuit,
pulling at the garment with enough strength
to tug his entire body forward.
In a blind panic, Javi tried to swipe the
Old Man’s rotting arm away, feeling an intense
burning,
almost like a chemical scalding his skin as
the same black ooze burned through his clothing
and started to singe his chest.
Another hand shot forward out of the puddle
on the wall, a clawed thumb puncturing Javi’s
side.
He screamed in pain as he felt the blistering
digit pierce into him,
while the rest of the fingers pulled him closer
still to the wall, using the hole in his side
like a handle.
The stench of his own burning flesh mixed
with the air of rotting decay that SCP-106
brought with it everywhere.
The decaying face of the Old Man peered through
the black slime on the wall,
its mouth locked in a sadistic, sinister grin
as Javi found himself pulled inside.
It almost felt like he had fallen asleep in
the bathtub,
and woken up gasping and spluttering, just
having narrowly avoided drowning.
Except now he was waking up in an entirely
different space, the transition there having
done little to dull the pain of his injuries.
Sitting up as he arrived in his new dark and
desolate surroundings, Javi gripped his side
and winced at the searing pain.
Then, the sudden smell of burning plastic
crawled up his nostrils and down the back
of his throat.
Most of the equipment the Foundation had strapped
onto him was melting;
the heart rate monitor and camera corroding,
covered in more of that black sludge.
Standing up, gritting his teeth through the
pain of his wounds, Javi quickly removed the
devices as carefully as he could.
He was far beyond caring about the Foundation’s
‘expedition’, right now, he just wanted
to get back out of… wherever the hell this
place was.
Checking over his shoulder, the slick, corrosive
puddle he’d been pulled through was already
gone.
At any rate, Javi didn’t particularly like
the idea of going back that way, so was relieved
– although he’d soon find out that relief
was perhaps misplaced.
He had barely a few moments to examine his
surroundings, not that there was much he could
see besides endless dark corridors…
and the withered figure of the Old Man.
It had reappeared, looking like it was far
off in the distance before, in a split second,
the gap between SCP-106 and Javi had closed.
The creature tilted its bald, skeletal head
as it looked at him, and he got a full, unobscured
glimpse at its sunken eyes and face locked
in a perpetual lipless grin.
The rotting, wrinkly flesh of the Old Man’s
body was oozing more and more of that dark,
disgusting mucus,
droplets of it landing on Javi’s clothing
and burning holes right through.
One hand still applying pressure to his side,
Javi turned and tried to run as far and fast
as his body was able.
If getting away was his sole objective, he
wanted out as quick as possible,
anything to get away from the nightmarish
creature he had now found himself trapped
with.
Running didn’t seem to work though.
He was sure he had made it at least a few
feet,
the Old Man was still standing behind him
but looked to be at more of a distance.
That was, until Javi noticed his legs; they
were running backwards.
Each step he had taken away from SCP-106 was
being reversed, rewound like on an old VHS
tape,
bringing him back closer and closer to the
creature’s clutches.
Its claws pushed painfully through Javi’s
back as it reversed time right back to the
point where he had turned to run away.
As the Old Man reached through him, more of
that burning, acidic pain starting eating
away at its captive D Class prey,
with Javi letting out a pained scream.
It wasn’t until several minutes in that
he realized something that hurt almost just
as bad:
SCP-106 could have killed him in an instant.
That much was clear.
But it hadn’t.
It had chosen not to.
Instead, it was torturing him, prolonging
the pain Javi was experiencing…
because it wanted him to suffer.
With all its strength, SCP-106 hurled him
several feet, until Javi’s burning, corroding
body collided with a hard surface, a wall,
with a loud crack.
The Old Man then manipulated the time within
his pocket dimension, causing Javi to fly
backward through the air,
back into the creature’s corrosive grip.
It allowed time to keep winding back, undoing
all the damage it had done so far.
As much as Javi was relieved to be rid of
the searing pain he was in, a sick worry deep
in the pit of his stomach told him that this
wasn’t an act of mercy;
the Old Man just wanted to make him suffer
all over again.
He lost track of how long it went on for,
SCP-106 taking sick glee in hurting his captive,
only to reverse the time within the pocket
dimension and do it all again.
Each time felt just like the first, made worse
by the fact that Javi never had a chance to
get used to the pain, to become numb to it.
Instead, every moment the torture started
was just like the first time, in fact, it
technically was.
Screaming in agony, Javi had no clue if he
had been there for hours, days, months, or
even years.
Had any time passed at all?
How many times had the Old Man done this to
him,
only to reverse time and do it all over again,
letting the pain begin anew?
Every few tries, the Old Man would release
Javi for a moment.
But once again, it was never done out of any
sense of mercy or kindness.
It was so it could hunt him.
Still, Javi ran every time, as far and fast
as he could, searching every corner of the
dark, desolate place for some kind of way
out.
A portal home, another of those corrosive
black puddles, a big door with ‘Exit’
written on it in big red letters.
But instead, all he found was SCP-106… or
rather, the Old Man found him.
It was hunting him again.
Javi had no idea how many times this made.
Panting, he slowed to a halt, trying to catch
his breath.
Reaching out in the dark, he put a hand against
a nearby hard surface, a wall… then felt
a crack under his hand.
Examining closer, although he could barely
see it, Javi could feel, with absolute certainty,
that the wall had been damaged, just a little.
It was the same one, the exact same wall he
had been thrown against, who knew how long
ago.
But the point was, it was still cracked from
where his body had hit it, even after the
Old Man had reversed time to hurt Javi over
and over again, the damage had stayed.
He had no way of knowing if it would work,
or how long it would take, but it might have
been a way out.
Desperately, Javi slammed his fist against
the wall, feeling pain shooting through his
fingers and up into his arm as it collided
with the solid surface.
Nothing changed.
Winding back the other arm, he hit it again.
Still nothing.
Javi could hear the Old Man shuffling closer
behind him, could sense his hands reaching
out closer to torture him again.
He let it happen, striking one last blow against
the wall before it finally reached him, and
the pain began once more,
only to be reversed so SCP-106 could do it
all again.
But now, he had a goal.
Each time the creature rewound time and undid
all the damage to its captive’s body,
Javi went looking for that same wall, feeling
across every surface until he reached it again.
The damage was still there, only a tiny crack
for now, but time – despite being under
the Old Man’s control in this pocket dimension
– was on Javi’s side.
Whenever he made it back to the wall, he started
to punch at it again, pounding one fist against
it after the other.
He didn’t relent, despite the pain it caused
him, he told himself it would be worth it
if it meant he made it out.
Even the times when the bones in his hands
broke, and he was flimsily striking at the
cracked wall with shattered fingers, he didn’t
stop.
It would be worth it.
It had to be, no matter how long it took.
He would gradually chip away at the wall,
more and more.
Every time SCP-106 would find Javi, and when
it did, it would hurt him.
The pain he’d put himself through trying
to break down the wall helped numb some of
the torture before the Old Man and reset everything
again.
Then, the hunt began again, and Javi went
back to making his gradual dent in the wall.
The whole time, he remembered he was doing
it for Kali, for his freedom, and a fresh
start.
Until, eventually, it stopped.
Javi had no idea how many times he’d struck
the wall, but it had been enough to start
tunneling through it slightly, both hands
bloody and broken again.
But this time, the Old Man didn’t appear.
It had stopped.
Screaming in rage, Javi started throwing himself
at the indented wall, trying desperately to
chip away more,
completely unaware that SCP-106 had left him
alone in its pocket dimension.
Back in their facility, the Foundation had
lost contact with Javi’s recording devices
over three hours ago,
at which point they had initiated their Recall
Protocol,
injuring the D Class they had chosen as a
lure.
Sure enough, the Old Man had reappeared from
his pocket dimension, following the pained
screams to come and finish the lure off.
There was no sign of Javi, and with a sigh,
the head researcher simply noted down:
‘SCP-106 Pocket Dimension Escape Test.
Result: test inconclusive.’
Now go check out SCP-106 CONTAINMENT BREACH”
and “SCP-106 CAUSED A SCHOOL LOCKDOWN”
for stories of a few other situations where
unsuspecting victims found themselves being
hunted by the Old Man... and whether or not
they too lived to talk about it.